[Music]
good job
[Music]
I still remember that day we're sitting
out front trying to figure out what was
going to be the name and because of the
city that we're starting with Byron
Georgia I said um maybe Byron been in
their Hospital
why you start laughing man
hey man we crew we Face crackers so he
came up with critifix initially I was
like that is country
let's see hey boy
it's a little little bunny
see any wounds on it
Kim Guidry brought in an injured bunny
yeah it's got a little Blood on the arm
right there and my fur little friend
last night while we were cleaning up the
dinner dishes my daughter and I heard a
noise out
brought us a baby bunny I need to get
you warmed up though it's awful cool
I'm getting shaved up and getting warm I
don't know don't get going here okay
if you can imagine the giant coming out
of the sky and just grabbing you and and
maiming you that's kind of how these
guys feel so they're traumatized they've
got lacerations of bleeding you don't
have the mother's heat you don't have
the mother's milk you have a lot to
overcome to get them back to health but
we just got to work hard together and
see if we can make it live
the big thing is functional I want to
make sure it's it's right on this arm
but I don't think it's in his chest
though what a thing
trip
yeah it sounds fine there maybe it's
superficial seem to be right
superficially on the the muscle area
this bunny got away with only a minor
wound but there are other concerns for
the baby oh you give me a warm my warm
gloves
thank you
and no I know you sound like Ferguson
when he hungers
probably worse than that when I'm hungry
all right we're gonna improvise and make
sure a warm bed right quick I know we
gotta warm you up
no matter what species this man was the
babies they have to have warmth because
they cannot control their body
temperature so they need a source of
heat once the temperature gets a certain
level and drops a few degrees they
absolutely will not eat hey
Phillips
that's what you was hauling for
[Music]
ah sugar it's a little more oh yum yum
yum yum yum yum yum yum yum yum
teamwork made to what DreamWork all
right
all right
was able to get in the drink got his
blood sugar up okay there's a
superficial wound but we clean it and
then we're glad it grew back you know
the hardest part
taking care of it
my daughter and I are gonna be here
so she gets a little bigger my daughter
is like I think this is a gift from God
I've always wanted to hold a little baby
bunny steal the gloves sounding worn you
can heat these up it'll eat all right
thank you so much no problem thank you
so much
mohawk
[Laughter]
that's it oh you may ask for the
handsome guy and they know what to do up
front
Buckley's here to get his knees fixed
Buckley a four-year-old Chiweenie is
here for knee surgery
we did she fed him treats all the time
yes he got traits and he's my little
sweet baby
hello hi what's up baby
anytime you have joint issues
being heavy is counterproductive and
when we're dealing with the weight thing
Buckley is a dog that's been loved on a
lot Buckley issues genetics
it's more common in a toy Breeze than
the small breed dogs they have we call a
luxating patella which basically means
the kneecap flips out a joint and is
dislocated
we have to do surgery all right you'd be
good boy
you'd be a good boy all right come on
man all right
Dr Ferguson is one of the best
orthopedic surgeons all right Buck are
you doing good buddy you ain't met a lot
of people have you I'm gonna lie okay I
really just want to be sure that you've
met more people I wasn't number one on
the list of one
[Music]
give him some happy juice and get him on
cloud nine
I'm happy juice all right
nighty night Baby next thing you
remember
we'll be up with brand new knees how
about that
it's Dr Ferguson preps for surgery Mario
waits for Buckley to get sleepy I'll go
night night boo boo
I'm ready for you Mario
if only I could go to sleep that easy
although Buckley's surgery is routine
there are always concerns when going
under anesthesia you always run a risk
of having issues with anesthesia no
matter what type of surgery you're doing
we run free anesthetic blood work to try
to lessen those unforeseen things that
can happen as long as we're prepared it
makes it a lot better
DR Horton hadn't had a whole lot of
Orthopedic experience so I'm showing her
what to do how to do this surgery I'm
going to start with a cranial lateral
incision here
now the kneecap is here normally would
be there
okay and then it has been doing this the
patellar Groove is too shallow allowing
the need to continuously pop out of
alignment which can be painful for
Buckley that's why we're gonna
discomfort so so that's where our
kneecap rides up and down
see it's not it's not a big Ridge there
but we're gonna we're gonna open it up
some give me some get some flush ready
Mario we're going to actually rasp or
file down under here to make this groove
deeper with this kind of speeds it up a
little bit here
as Dr Ferguson works on Buckley's knee
an emergency comes in for Dr Hodges hey
hey summer hey give me some hand I got a
C-section up front Wylie come on
can we get this move
give me a glue glow blue
blue boss man we on Deck 10 15. all
right DD an American Bulldog is in labor
with one puppy stuck in the birth canal
when the Mercers come in everything
changes it's like a triage now that I
know the heart just needs the surgery
room my thought process is it's
something serious you're probably going
to take both of us so I need to finish
so we can have the room as well as we
can both double team this thing and try
to get it under control I have to do
this surgery quickly but I have to do it
well
[Music]
I know I know I know I know
Bulldogs typically they're born with
really large heads and a lot of times
you have to do cesarean sections to make
sure they come out safely in this case
the owner saw one passion thought maybe
it could come out but the head got stuck
everything spiraled down here and at
this point DD's life is in Jeopardy and
the puppy's life is in Jeopardy yeah go
ahead and pull it out I'm sure it stuck
so I would like to get try to get this
one out his head is actually stress
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
looking at the pope and knowing how long
it's been there three hours I knew there
was no way this pepper probably was a
lot
no heartbeat on that one
he's
three hours kind of got a long time a
long time yeah hang out but
all right we're gonna make sure we say
the rest of them though
once I realized that this puppy was
deceased I knew it was time to move on
and and do what I was trained to do and
get the rest of these babies out alive
shade let's get it ready to go you
wouldn't have emergency section when you
have bilateral patella luxation surgery
on you but you know we can't can't
schedule everything
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
we're almost done buckling is looking
good
Dr Ferguson wraps up Buckley's surgery
so Dr Hodges can get DD's emergency
C-section started all right bro talk to
me when you're getting ready we ready
all right
[Music]
the text quickly transferred DD and
Buckley as the docs prepped for surgery
that's our incubator ready
power's ready incubator real people
ready
all right we're going exterior off this
uterus Dr Hodges will need to remove the
puppies quickly if they are to have any
chance of survival all right we're gonna
take out one horn
and see if we can milk some puppies some
sponges his first baby gonna be
stretched suction go ahead and give me
another towel open up some Motown
[Music]
still there's still two more in this
pack though
oh it's blue come on come on come on
come on
is blue all hands on deck I need another
hand I need somebody I need somebody I
don't my baby right here is not
breathing
I think somebody need somebody
need somebody hey the next one is blue
after struggling to give birth to her
first puppy Dede the American Bulldog is
undergoing an emergency C-section to
save her litter all hands on deck I need
another hand
okay get ready for another one all right
we got another stress baby he's out this
one out of the sack
they're pretty come here poppy come here
I'm gonna need another hand okay
typically we don't have clients
following the patients back in the
emergency situation but you know at this
point hey it's all hands on Dick let's
save these babies I just need you just
stimulate them see to increase blood
flow if a pup is born not breathing and
it has been a very long time we usually
can resuscit that puppy we can do CPR we
have aspirators to aspirate all the
fluid out of the nose and the biggest
thing we want to get that puppy warm
because it has to be warm to go ahead
and start breathing the old days you say
slap a baby on the button to start
crying but don't quite slap them on the
butt but we're massaging we're basically
stimulating getting all the body
functions back together
right here
yeah I need somebody to get the baby
let's roll let's roll nobody crying this
is stress all right well this isn't the
stress something you're gonna have to
come and get two anything going out
there
my baby right here is not breathing he's
the very first one that came out the
very first one come on come on come on
come on
uh it would go
the head is huge we'll see anything
going on there talk to me
the worst thing a Veterinary can hear is
when you ask your team what's going on
and they're stopped
I hadn't heard any peeps out of my eight
puppies
so my heart drops
talk to me
it's a slow process trying to get a
little colorful come on come on come on
come on come on you're a big one come on
come on come on
he's not breathing we're still
I got a breath I got a breath all right
[Music]
come on yeah
sounds like good news out here
they were stressed already and then in
addition to we put mama if I need some
anesthesia so they gotta live that too
that's why I was taking a little time to
come out
there we go I got two breasts you got
anything out there
I got three crime babies okay 100 yes
sir your magic numbers eight only eight
we got you what y'all got yeah she
breathing she just ain't squeaking it
but she is breathing
come on
yeah
[Music]
I want to hear eight Ocho drill
together
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
laughs
don't worry boss man I think you got it
from here all right bro
all right
okay they're doing good over here Drew
okay so the two they're a little slower
that girl the boys no they boys you know
boys are a little slower sometimes yeah
come around huh what yeah they are okay
talk to him come on
I would say we got one that's slow
coming around all I want to hear is Ocho
he gonna be mad that's the name gonna be
Ocho Ocho have it go perfect
no doubt nice and pink
oh you hit it I heard it I heard it well
y'all look like proud daddies over there
like in the living room y'all look like
y'all y'all in the living room that's it
this is beautiful beautiful look yeah
especially when you get a little like
this how could you not be happy how
could you not be man you made me work
for it boy
but I don't mind working if you're gonna
work with me
so then we were fortunate enough to save
all the puppies that were being held up
by that one puppy you know it was sad to
lose that one but we was quick to action
and we were able to save all the rest
she trying to take my pick look up you
can go
yeah but see they all they all look real
good
[Music]
don't be scared we are here with the
zoos to fix his eyes because he was born
with inverted eyelids Zeus a Russian
hairless cat known as a Don score is
here for surgery to correct a painful
eye condition hey what's up
who are you all right look how big he is
now I know
still holding those eyes shut a little
bit oh yeah yeah this this one got a
little worse
and tropion is what we call this
condition the margins of the eyelids
have curled in and so it scratches this
poor cat's eyes and the big problem is
if that hair keeps continuously
scratching the corner they go blind so
what we have to do is get those eyelids
and cut those margins so they're back to
normal it's gotten worse I'm gonna fix
it
thank you guys me and Paul are gonna
make sure this goes perfect
[Music]
let's go get them fixed
let me kiss
[Music]
you're gonna be okay wait baby I guess I
got you
hey
I'm gonna make you a new man you can be
able to see
huh I'm always nervous it doesn't matter
what but I trust him okay
nobody touched my kids but him all right
Dr Hodges and Paul ready Zeus for this
delicate surgery the most difficult part
of entropion surgery is I need just the
right amount of mom could on this side
and just the right amount on the other
side because if you take too much out
you could do just as much harm creating
the opposite problem which is called egg
tropion and the eyelid kind of hangs
which isn't healthy for this cast tissue
so you got to be perfect with the
surgery you gotta get this right brother
can I get a dress right
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
cat is in the middle of a delicate eye
surgery
this is called The hoax h-o-t-z Celsius
method where we cut almost a half moon
as I cut my small moon piece up I am
taking the top piece bring it down to
the bottom of my moon grabbing it
bringing it through
and hopefully when I get rid of Tie My
Suits or not it inverts
the top of the eyelid back
oh I see some eyelid Andrea hey good
granddaddies would say we cooking with
grease now I see it all the way around
all right so we got out of this when the
swelling goes down
it should close nice okay that's one
side but we not the woods yet
my hands still steady follow me
voila so I can see all Lids now so now
we have a cat that we can see the the
margins eyes look good got to get the
puffiness to go down and we should be
seeing very well hey
so
we're good but I just want to warn you
for a couple days it's gonna look like
we've been in a boxing match but we're
just gonna put some cream in It's Gonna
it's gonna be fine it's like any plastic
surgery just like the exact same me up
next
summer going on here okay so so you can
see you see that
you see how you can see it now so you
can see the whole eye it's just the this
part is swelling there so all you're
gonna do is just kind of put the cream
here
first oh my goodness gracious oh my God
I'm freak out because I see the eyes you
know it's like it's scary but it's for
the best
Dr Ferguson and Senior vet tech Jordan
head out to a farm to see a pot belly
pig with an attitude problem hello Miss
Lewis hey how are you doing today I
heard you got something to see today
we'll be checking out Zoe Zoe
we just got a call from a homeowner who
said that pig that she has been very
aggressive and a problem they can't
control it and they want to know what
they can do if you fix it
why don't we have all this around the
fence because she's been um get out
she's been getting out yeah
we've been having an issue with our Pig
getting out of the pen and tearing up
our entire yard and we're really not
sure exactly what to do to fix that and
then you can sprink your ankle if you
found one of the holes
hard to keep her in huh she like to use
that nose don't you yeah and our whole
yard looks like this when she gets out
oh first look this baby over let me see
if we can hear something
oh you want to stop rooting yeah rooting
is natural pigs use their snout to to
burrow to find food for thermal reasons
cooling off there is no way to stop them
you will be stopping what Mother Nature
gave them how to be resourceful
we were just thinking that if the ring
was in her nose it would irritate her so
she wouldn't root so bad was our thought
probably not okay one start to disrupt
the pig's natural rooting Behavior
putting a ring into Zoe's snout not only
won't stop her rooting but it's likely
to be painful we don't really know how
to stop him from rude because that's
just what they do that's their nature
that's their nature whatever area you
put the pig in we just have to allow it
in the beer to do their thing that's one
of the things when you got a pig it kind
of comes along with it just let her out
every now and then you don't have to
leave her out okay you know just get out
and get a little stretch making sure Zoe
gets enough exercise will keep her from
being bored and may reduce the amount of
rooting she does
you ready to go run
hello come on I think I'm faster than a
pig
[Music]
I think that was me so you like animals
yeah you want to be a veterinarian yeah
y'all can have a day off of me and Emma
dude oh that's a good idea sound like a
winner
when you're coming tomorrow be good
not tomorrow oh you have school okay
see you later Future Been There spring
break I'm waiting on you so I can go
home okay
oh I have to work okay
all right there we go
lots of good information today
rooting it's a pig's nature ultimately
we just want somebody to be happy
so who won the race so we won for sure
there's only one maybe next time
[Music]
it's been one of those days
come on y'all might have to call it a
human fix
[Laughter]
everything
in the clinic I mean we'll have the day
planned we have X amount of surgeries in
the morning x amount of appointments
then you get a call to go out and see a
pig yeah or you get a call a C-section
is on the way or you get a call is hit
by a car and then I go hide in the room
where there's a vaccine for a puppy
Dr Hodges
he's TV he's always going to be there
all right it's all right
hey Paul Travis is having trouble
breathing yeah
Animal Control brought us in a duck that
was found on the side of the road
because he really needed some emergency
care what's going on okay he's been
gasping for air and he also not walking
right not fighting at all either
this bird was in trouble he was open
mouth breathing which tell me he really
isn't getting a whole lot of oxygen if
we did not get Petersburg some kind of
treatment for the restoration he's gonna
die hey what's going on with you
we got some crackles in the lungs I'm
hearing a lot of crackles I mean it
actually sounds like a bag of corn chips
that's how we know that they're slower
than the lungs we need to fix this
basket can I get my mobile oxygen when
I'm taking in here with this oxygen see
if we can get an x-ray on his leg and
get an x-ray on the side and see if I
can figure out what's exactly going on
oh man
oh boy oh that don't sound good
oh man oh boy oh that don't sound good
local animal control brought in an
injured duck found on the side of the
road sick bird
so we had a chest cavity that's
clouded we got a respiratory infection
on top of the respiratory infection
total fracture this bone
should be connected here we may be a
inch apart so that is bad really bad
[Music]
other again
you might have to hang out in hotel
Hodges for a little while
get you fixed up happy beating a mile a
minute let's pray animals ducks are
easily stressed Dr Hodges decides to
give the duck a break from being handled
while still treating him
for now let's go ahead and put them in
oxygen chamber so you can kind of
breathe
and uh we're gonna get a game plan to
fix that leg
we decided to put him in the oxygen
chamber so that he could just get more
oxygen saturation would give antibiotics
and diuretic that will help remove some
of the fluid from the chest hopefully
it's going to get him stable so that we
can move on and repair this broken leg
prognosis is very very guarded
[Music]
six weeks ago Buckley had bilateral
patella luxation surgery
he my little sweet baby
ever since then Buckley postoperly had
been back in the bandages are off and
that you've been down there we're gonna
see who who Mohawk looks the best man
after a couple of weeks Buckley has been
repairing orthopedically yeah just walk
through and take a look
he's doing great with his weight he
looks tremendous he's nine and a half
pounds lighter so he's losing the weight
and he's getting his energy back and
he's he's acting like Buckley and he's
playing with his favorite toy the empty
Coke bottle so now and we know he's
getting better okay bye-bye Buckley's on
prognosis is great he's walking around
good and I'm confident that Buckley's
owner is going to take care of Buckley
[Music]
it's been a couple of days since Animal
Control brought an injured duck to
Critter Fixer and Dr Hodges has been
working to get his respiratory infection
under control
oh yeah that's way better
no open mouth breathing no crackles
all right part one is fixed now he can
move on to repairing the duck's broken
leg we were able to get this plate
x-rated and we found out that it is a
break we're going to stabilize this leg
with the splint veterinary medicine we
have a saying if we can get bone to bone
touching it'll hit Mother Nature will
take care of it we just need to hold it
together long enough for her to do so
it's not really any pain which is great
hold up
so good job stabilize this thing Dr
Hodges splints the duck's leg to
immobilize it while it heals wrapping it
up will keep the leg from moving too
much while allowing the duck to walk
I don't know
[Music]
so much better you could be quack
quacking with the ducks in the pond any
moment brother
all right you better not let them pick
on you okay
but you don't got fun today
[Music]
I chose this name Alfie even though you
know he was hurt he still had this oral
about him like he was just like I'm
African
but you know he was just something else
with a little TLC and Andrea yeah was
loving on him he's doing so much better
all right so who's that that thing
stabilized
hey good luck great noise but you got to
go home
damn control is coming to pick Alfie up
and we're going to a rehab down in
Hawkinsville Georgia and you are going
to get better
[Music]
all right we're gonna go ahead and go to
room two okay
I run a reptile rescue a lady had a
tortoise and she decided to surrender
the tortoise to us and we brought it
straight here he's got a cut above his
head behind his neck and it's really
infected no idea what happened to him if
it doesn't have medical attention it's
definitely going to die not a lot of
room in here so let's wheel him in the
back and we'll all take a look here okay
oh my yeah
all right you got your scale ready
I don't know if it's gonna be big enough
but
whoa
let's take a look
looks like the biggest tortoise I've
ever seen prehistoric toys they've been
here way before we die almost 67 pounds
a dead weight but hey where the Critter
fixing some Cowabunga all right we may
be able to stand them up on his hand you
can probably see it better just flip him
straight up
there you go
we do have maggots
we're gonna need some help DR Horton
we got a surprise for you come here
so
so what's the plan that trying to clean
this area out
we got maggots
for our pet has pets been there for a
while oh yeah here we have this big
tortoise that has been injured with a
huge gaming room under a seal and we
gotta figure out how we're gonna fix how
we're gonna remove these maggots and get
rid of this necrotic tissue if the
injury is untreated the bacteria grows
you start to get necrotic the flies lay
the eggs in there the magnets start
eating the wounds and start really
smelling and start oozing and so we have
a tortoise that has a really serious
bacteria infection
foreign
off to get to it this is a lot worse
than I thought these maze are irritating
the skin they're burning down eating the
tissue this is definitely life three
[Music]
[Music]
oh our pet has pets
a large sulcata tortoise has been
brought in for treatment of a serious
wound but the tortoise has other
problems and lots of them so as I get in
to start working on this horse and start
to brighten the necrotic tissue I
noticed ah pockets and pockets of
maggots why are they coming out of there
you don't woke them up wake these
maggots up
dead tissue
the last spot where I cut there's a lot
of necrosis of maggots
basic necrosis is dead tissue and so
dead tissue won't heal maggots do eat
the necrotic tissue but they also will
delay healing as well so really you want
to get those guys out I'm gonna flush
this thing out
[Music]
oh yeah whoa jackpot jackpot wow oh yeah
it doesn't work
sure we gonna go home with a song just
look at them as flies
look at them crawling out of there get
out of my womb maggots
that's the last pocket of maggots
look at that good red tissue
just make sure there's nothing hiding
there I don't see anymore
but that looks really good that is
beautiful everybody say it together
beautifully
you finally got it cleaned out and flush
the most the mags but this tortoise is
still not where I want it prognosis is
guarded when you have that much tissue
loss sometimes tissue is so necross we
have to let wounds here by secondary
healing we just let Mother Nature let
that tissue granulate in so in order
needs to make sure that it keeps that
area clean and not allow bacteria to get
within it so I'm gonna send you at home
with some medicine put some this
sulfacility and cream on the inside put
it down in there yeah try to put it in
let's pack and let's try to get it all
over this flesh a lot of times when
people get burned this this kind of this
is what we use on this is a human
medicine that is an antibiotic
properties as well as anti-inflammatory
gotcha how often do we need to do that
you're gonna do it three times a day if
you can that's fine and hopefully we
have a turtle that is around for another
100 years
all right but what you think
you live through it good job
all right man thank you sir no problem I
don't have maggots on your hands
so you're gonna feel a lot better
[Music]
this is not something that was a very
easy job to do
there we go
bringing it here was a really good
decision
let's go
[Music]
recently the docs performed an emergency
C-section on DD his first baby gonna be
stressed and delivered eight baby
bullies I finally got a breath
now these puppies are living their lives
stress-free DD doing great she really
taking to the pups real nice being that
this is our first litter I really feel
like she's doing good really taking care
of the pups she's not too rough with him
or anything like that they all bought
him home from surgery she started
lactating real well and she's been a
real good mom but we love all of our
dogs and take real good care of them
looks really good Zeus the cat is back
to have his stitches removed so we're
going to check out Zeus's eyes hopefully
when
I opened it right
to the eyelid because before when I was
doing Zeus's zootopia on surgery the
eyelids were bent down they were just
scraping the eye itself so if I see an
eyelid and I see the eyes and if the
client tells me that he's not constantly
squinting and blinking his eyes then I
know the surgery is a success
[Music]
oh wow I was really worried about the
actual eye
itself being damaged the eyeball itself
looks really really good
I mean there's no scraping I mean if I
ever have to get a facelift this is what
I want to look like
I'm even shocked so what we was really
worried about like the eye and the
corneum scratch yeah perfect perfect I
knew it
is
so much
[Music]
appreciated no problem time to go home
yes be so grateful for everything that
the hash did for us
every single day we see multiple animals
snakes dogs Birds cats chickens camels
horses donkey iguana oh keep going are
you hot bearded dragon keep going you
hot rabbits ah Pig you on fire hold on
we're ready for the final round you
ready
[Music]
I'll take cows for 1 000. we have a
winner
[Music]
come on
you all right I see it I'm doing good to
see you good to see you today I'm gonna
take care of these boys of yours all
right thank you sir we're here at the
greenway Farm to castrate some Bulls
today because they aren't breeding
animals just like doing a spay or the
neuter and dogs and cats as well you
know it's a little bit more um intense
intense than castrating the dog stop
bringing them to you gotta work all
right sir all right by having the vents
come out we let the big doctor and small
doctor tackle the six and seven hundred
pound calves we get to watch
yeah
catch him in the front shoot we're going
to put a boot calves in what we call a
shoot and what the shoot does it
squeezes the cow and it holds his head
so that we can get in and we can do the
work that we need to do so it serves two
purposes it protects the cow as well as
it protects us once immobilized Dr
Ferguson moves in behind the young ball
for the procedure right behind you with
some alcoholics slide it up there we go
quick and easy
I remember 20 years ago use a lot faster
goes away
on the procedure there are a couple
different things you can use we use a
Newberry knife and it's made where it
cuts both sides of the scrotum at one
time so that we don't have to go in and
make two incisions once we make one
incision both testicles drop and we cut
them and remove them from the body it's
a little bit uncomfortable for a few
minutes but it's not a long-term pain
here you go boss
the castration is performed quickly and
the area is covered by an antibacterial
spray that contains fly repair once we
spray them down to make sure they don't
get flies or infection we let them out
and they usually go back in the pasture
they graze they drink water and they're
back to normal bring him to me if you
can all right
[Music]
there we go buddy
come on
stay behind us
he got out
[Music]
bring him to me if you can Dr Ferguson
and Dr Hodges are out at Greenway Farms
of Georgia castrating young bull calves
today
he got out hold off wait a minute Rob
yeah I'm coming the docs need to perform
a castration on this 700 pound bull calf
let's go get you some water
come on that's it yeah we need to hurry
up and get him we're gonna do it
you ready
holding the cow's tail that's one of the
most important part of restraint it
keeps them from kicking as much so you
restrain the tail the shoot holds the
animal in it allows us to get into our
work
all right
yeah there you go let him sort of find
his way out all right but when he gets
healed up we'll move him on over with
some of these young heifers
the doc did a great job they've been
doing a great job for us for several
years now we really appreciate them
coming out doing this for me thank you
man I know my hand 30.
and we'll see you back in the office
thanks yes ma'am yes ma'am don't always
have been great clients through the
years they come in with their babies we
take care of them and I'm more than
happy to come out today to take care of
the cows
[Music]
let's testosterone I got you thanks man
I appreciate that yeah
[Music]
the winner had all the maggots oh we got
maggots
Grace is alive man that tortoise was in
bad shape the reptile rescue that we
took him to took him home and you never
gonna believe what happened
when we got that tortoise in I mean it
was it was really really bad and what I
thought was probably beyond the point of
really being able to do much for it but
um
he made it which was a big surprise to
me once he started eating we couldn't
stop him from eating and wanting to walk
around and get into everything and so
now he's acting like a tortoise should
unless you look and see his injury where
the wound was you'd never know anything
was ever wrong
[Music]
mouth has been out at rehab for a few
weeks how are you looks like you found
me I found you outfit kind of presented
in the clinic in Dire Straits I was
worried you know we kind of got a scene
a sick bird is usually a dead bird and
here we are weeks later we came to see
how he's doing you doing okay today
doing good my rehab animals mostly
domestics I do uh fostering dogs I have
a lot of Yard Birds turkeys peacocks
guineas I got pigeons I got Ducks I got
chickens
Alfie
he's the newest edition you want to go
see Alfie let's see if
Salford you got a nice little hospital
to see buddy I mean you got everything
around you
like we talked about this thing was in
three pieces three pieces let's see him
walk around
perfect he's bearing weight he's moving
around so we're making progress you'll
be out here running with the running
with these little ducks really soon
great job that's what we do
[Music]
this is where all the ducks like to stay
hey this is where Alfia get to swim this
is unbelievable
can I play coach
can I play now hey horsey what's going
on how are you Dr Hodges is out there
kissing on a horse don't bite my nose
you're gonna eat grass can I talk to you
you're not gonna talk to me all right
I'll go find a new friend
nobody want to be my friend [ __ ]
somebody want to be my friend
girlfriend
hello
oh this is George at his best bro we're
gonna go see a pigeon we're gonna go see
some pigeons they come from people in
town that have found them falling out of
the nest kind of thing so oh that is
beautiful look at these guys
look at this so how old are these guys
man two weeks oh wow look at that ball
they're very warm super warm I'm up
there at little box there's two eggs we
got two eggs 18 days we'll have baby
pigeons uh-huh
anybody want me to look at while I'm out
here I've got a microchip if you can put
it in the day I'll be glad to do it
foreign
[Music]